lady gaga just had one of her most  cringe-worthy interviews yet mother  monster appeared to have her poker face  on during Friday's episode of BBC  Breakfast refusing to answer questions  about the upcoming presidential election  and the Republican presidential nominee  Donald Trump you've declared your  backing for Hillary Clinton yes I mean  there there will be a new president  it could be Donald Trump I have nothing  to save him  journalist charlie state pushed the  issue further and things only got more  awkward I'm intrigued that you that you  literally won't say anything about him  you have endorsed Hillary Clinton I mean  what is it you think that she is gonna  do for the USA that he will not  I think she will do a good job some  people want to win races  other people want to be President of the  United States  [Music]  you